topping the charts for nearly 30 years
with songs like vogue Madonna has made a
fortune from her music career with over
300 million albums sold worldwide she
also holds the record for the most
successful tour by a solo artist in
history last year's mdna tour made
nearly three hundred million dollars but
as the queen of pops career developed so
have her business interests nowadays
music is just one string to her bow with
the opening of her latest hard candy gym
in Rome Maja's taped into a fitness
market that's doubled in size in under
ten years she's already released the
fitness DVD too then there's Madonna's
truth or dare ranges these include her
perfume and shoe collections she's also
targeted the teenage fashion market with
material girl a joint venture with her
own daughter the 55 year old has also
jumped on the nutritional bandwagon
having bought a stake in vita coco then
there's the property portfolio having
picked up real estate in prime locations
in central London a New York Central
Park Madonna has been pretty savvy with
her spending tom gibson bloomberg